[Music]
brought to you by the every dooll app
start budgeting for free today today's
question comes from Bethany in Texas I
have been married to a lovely man for 15
years who loves me and adores my son he
is the best dad I could have given to my
son the problem is the finances I make
$180,000 as a nurse practitioner while
he makes 30,000 the issue is not really
the money but his lack of ambition to
make more of it he has so much potential
recently found him a job which will
double his salary but he's just not
interested I love him very much and I
need to know and I need to know how to
let him be since I realize I cannot make
him want to make more money I feel like
when it comes to the financial part of
our marriage he believes that it is my
responsibility I live in fear knowing
that if something happens to me where I
die or can no longer work my family
would lose everything how do I love my
husband husband the way he is since he
refuses to
change
Bethany
um the the biggest problem I see here
Bethany well number one I'm glad that
you just that you realize you can't
control him because you can't we can't
control other people and the fact that
it sounds like you're his mom I'm like
you went out and found him a job and
you're doing all of these things you're
being proactive while he's obviously not
wanting it so so I would say again the
money is not the issue here a lot of it
is fear that if something happens are
are are you going to be okay is your
family going to be okay and so that's
the approach I would take with him not
oh go double your salary but it's hey
this is what it's causing in me and it's
feeling like it's becoming a it's it's a
wedge between you and him I mean it just
naturally is and that fear possibly
might be in other parts of your marriage
and in your life together and so um
that's the way I would approach it more
versus from the money side more on what
it's causing in you but yeah I I feel
like be
harer I I I read that you don't respect
him that's what I
read and it has nothing to do with the
amount of money he makes that causes
respect his his lack of personal growth
in wanting to do better and wanting to
be better he is a lovely lazy man is
what I
read and you know that's a problem
because that's not going to get you're
not going to suddenly get okay with that
that's going to
deteriorate or improve it's not going to
stay right where it is and so uh I
really think that you guys need to sit
down with a good marriage counselor and
and then he the counselor hopefully can
plug him in with some guys who uh some
men who who are wanting to improve
themselves um it's hard to respect a
husband or or a wife that doesn't you
know that wants to sit like a
blob and um not improve I don't mind if
somebody makes 30,000 uh as long as
they're on their way to doing the best
version of themselves you know as long
as they're on their way to Growing
learning getting better and so forth and
then the the symptom of that problem is
that if you die I mean I don't know how
y'all are going to L are you lost you
know if you became disabled y'all are
going to lose everything you're right
because you've set yourself up on a an
unrealistic situation with incomes
dependent on you so I just I think I
think this has gone on for 15 years and
you've tolerated it and held your nose
because he's nice and know maybe the guy
before that you had the baby with is not
nice M you know yeah and so uh I don't
want him to be not nice but I do want
him to uh go be somebody well and the
fact Bethany I feel like he's not
hearing you right I'm like unless you're
not saying anything to him which would
be unhealthy too but I'm like there
there's something there that you don't
you don't feel hurt you feel like you're
on an island by yourself and you're
isolated and all the responsibil on you
and that's not a marriage a marriage is
a team you both are working together now
naturally always when it comes to these
kind of uh not this situation because
this is more extreme but naturally in a
marriage there's always going to be one
who's way more excited to do all the
budgeting and all the Excel and look at
all the and the rate of return I mean
there's naturally going to be one of you
that's more excited than the other with
this money stuff and that's okay like
that that is great but the fact that you
guys are not on the same page and you're
wanting something else from him that
he's not just not even giving you but
also not even giving you the dignity to
try to see where you're coming from and
meet you even halfway right I mean any
level of that give and take doesn't seem
to be there so create your free every
dooll budget today the simplest way to
budget for your life